[Musique]
bienvenue aujourd'hui paris saclay tv
vous emmène à la découverte de votre
territoire le plateau de saclay se
transforme se construit se métamorphose
alors quoi de mieux qu'une balade pour
découvrir ses nouveaux quartiers
vous étiez nombreux à visiter le campus
urbain de paris saclay lors des journées
nationales de l'architecturé d'autres
préfèrent le vélo à la marche
et pourquoi pas le pea paris saclay a
lancé le challenge vélo une semaine pour
aller à la rencontre des amoureux de la
petite reine un mode de transport qui
s'inscrit dans le projet vous une saclay
les explications dans un instant nous
reviendrons aussi sur l'événement french
tech s'est déroulée au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
ce rendez vous qui réunit les startups
du territoire va devenir récurrent
[Musique]
si vous êtes fidèles de paris-saclay tv
vous avez pu suivre au fur et à mesure
la création du campus urbain et
découvrir les nouveaux quartiers de
l'école polytechnique et de moulon ici
nous sommes dans une résidence qui vient
tout juste d'être livrés et ses
quartiers vous avez donc pu les arpenter
lors des journées nationales de
l'architecturé on vous emmène en balade
[Musique]
à l'occasion des journées nationales
architecture donc on a une visite ce
matin sur l'école polytechnique et cet
après midi sur le carte du moulon
c'était l'occasion de faire une grande
visite de la zac à la fois dans le
belvédère dans le quartier d'habitation
et en traversant sur le sur le deck
il y avait à la fois des familles avec
des enfants il y avait plus de 90
personnes des personnes qui habitent
laval et où qu'il habite aussi le
plateau qui sont intéressés qui viennent
s'installer sur le plateau qui sont déjà
donc ça a permis d'aller voir les
différents projets immobiliers notamment
ceux qui sont en construction et qui
sont assez structurant pour la zac de
voir les projets qui ont déjà été
réalisés il ya 2 3 ans etc ont déjà une
vie déjà dans le projet comme lee smolin
de bâtiments du belvédère et de finir
par le quartier d'habitation qui lui en
cours de livraison avec tous les espaces
8 qui sont indexés au rez-de-chaussée
tous les commerces et de voir un peu la
vie qui commence à s'implanter sur le
quartier notamment
les premiers logements que les premières
familles qui étaient au balcon ce week
end là donc c'était assez grave de se
balader avec tout le monde et tout le
monde a pris conscience aussi de
l'évolution du quartier là on en est
actuellement je pense que ces journées
sont extrêmement importante puisqu'on en
fait elles permettent de mesurer
finalement à la fois l'évolution du
projet paris saclay et de regarder son
évolution dans le temps et je pensais ça
va important aussi pour à la fois pour
l'ensemble du territoire c'est beaucoup
d'habitants finalement les gens louent
ce territoire et puis aussi pour qu'il y
ait une sorte de l'appropriation en fait
de ce projet c'est absolument essentiel
donc cette ouverture est très importante
pour que désordonné porte la
connaissance publique de ce qu'on est en
train de fabriquer aujourd'hui sur le
portier du moment où on a développé
beaucoup à la fois 2-2 aspect c'est à
dire la question du rapport au
territoire qui existent ou plutôt si les
gens qui habitent les gens qui
travaillent déjà depuis plusieurs
siècles
et puis ce nouveau quartier ses nouveaux
quartiers et donc quel rapport
entretient entre les deux et comment
finalement les espaces publics peuvent
fabriquer
finalement ce lien entre ces différents
quartiers à la fois nouveau des anciens
pour former qu'un seul et même
territoire si salah d'avoir une question
pas est un territoire surtout qu'ils
soient ici qu'ils soient situés sur ce
département sur l'yvette sur les
communes autour de l'yvette et fassent
partie intégrante de ce territoire
[Musique]
et maintenant si nous prenions un vélo
vous êtes nombreux à avoir choisi ce
mode de transport sur le plateau mais
comment faire mieux
le pea paris saclay avec l'agglomération
nokia et les associations cyclistes du
territoire ont décidé de vous mettre à
contribution avec le challenge vélo une
semaine pour mieux connaître vos trajets
une semaine pour promouvoir la petite
reine
grâce au projet maureen saclay
cette semaine c'est un challenge
organisé par le projet d'expérimentation
où une saclay
et donc on fait une semaine ou du vélo
on invite tous les cyclistes du plateau
de saclay à partager leur trajet pour
pouvoir
côté territoire mieux connaître
les déplacements des cyclistes et
pouvoir ensuite faire la promotion du
vélo à paris 5e c'est un projet qui a
été monté avec les associations
cyclistes plateau de saclay wind saclay
c'est une démarche initiée par le
territoire qui a mené à différents
projets innovants et un de ces projets
s'est développé une plateforme numérique
des mobilités qui a d'une part un
observatoire de mobilité qui agrège
différentes données du territoire pour
vraiment construire une connaissance
complète de la mobilité et d'une autre
part côté usagers c'est une application
pour concilier une bonne expérience
individuelle de la mobilité avec
l'intérêt général de territoire
l'objectif pour nous une saclay c'est
d'avoir un jeu donnait vraiment axé sur
le vélo pour recenser les trajets les
plus les plus empruntés le nombre de
cyclistes et pouvoir croiser ça aussi
avec d'autres données qu'on peut avoir
sur le vélo des boucles de comptage sur
les pistes cyclables pour construire un
premier socle première connaissance du
vélo sur le plateau de saclay
ce projet il est mené par un consortium
public privé avec les communautés
d'agglomération paris saclay et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines l'université
paris saclay d'instituts vd comme il le
fait à paris saclay et l'industriel
nokia bell labs
pour moi le vélo et de modes de
déplacement qui est potentiellement le
plus apte à résoudre les problèmes de
vrais problèmes de déplacement pour un
accès au plateau de saclay
particulièrement pour nous associations
tout ce qui peut favoriser les
déplacements à vélo est à prendre en
contre ça permet aussi de montrer qu'il
existe des itinéraires qu'on appelle
malins qui permettent de rejoindre le
plateau
à peu près à peu près à peu près en
sécurité et c'est très important
pour
je vous emmène à présent dans un haut
lieu du cyclisme le vélodrome national
de saint quentin en yvelines pour un
événement french tech
ce n'est pas le premier du genre neil
dernier le coprésident de la french tech
paris saclay veut rassembler les start
peur du territoire objectif les
mobiliser les mettre en réseau le tout
dans une ambiance festive
regardez bas french tech c'est
l'écosystème des startups françaises
c'est un label qui portait donc par
bercy qui est déclinée désormais sur une
centaine de communautés cinquantaine de
communautés en france sur les principaux
pôles d'activité
et puis une cinquantaine de communauté à
l'étranger
steck paris-saclay on va apporter des
événements comme comme l'événement de ce
soir on a l'intention d'en organiser
trois par an qui seront l'occasion pour
les start up de notre écosystème de se
rencontrer d'échanger toujours dans une
dans un contexte de convivialité
l'organisation sid événements
thématiques qui seraient pas couverts
et d'ateliers par exemple on va faire le
lien aussi avec les grands groupes du
territoire être le relais auprès des
pouvoirs publics et favoriser en fait
les connexions avec les offres qui sont
proposés à l'échelle nationale comme les
offres de dpi de business france sur le
financement et l'accompagnement à
l'export essayer de répondre aux
problématiques et le facilitateur en
essayant de mobiliser le réseau des
startups en général quand on est face à
une difficulté on
on a probablement d'autres entrepreneurs
qui ont vécu la même chose et en
facilitant les échanges je pense qu'on
pourrait être plus rapide et plus
efficace
ce soir c'était le deuxième événement
organisé par la franchise paris saclay
on a vu l'occasion 4 juillet de faire
une soirée de lancement qui avait
rassemblé nombreuses start-up du
territoire et aujourd'hui c'est un
nouveau rendez vous
donc le rendez vous de l'automne à
une configuration l'occasion de
rencontrer des interlocuteurs variés
d'avoir des speakers qu'ils nous ont
fait le plaisir de nous rejoindre
et puis maintenant un moment de
convivialité un buffet quelques bières
des jeux en réalité virtuelle de la
pétanque du ping pong manière à
favoriser les échanges et vraiment
structuré animé cette communauté de
start up
[Musique]
notre agenda à présent l'art
contemporain s'invite dans les villes du
territoire avec space une exposition à
ciel ouvert cette deuxième édition se
déroule jusqu'au 16 février et vous
pourrez même aller à la rencontre des
artistes
le comité de suivi des chantiers de le
paix à paris saclay rendez vous est pris
le lundi 9 décembre à 17 heures au
plateau des projets de le paix à paris
saclay a horse et enfin le proto bus
reprend la route
les équipes de l'établissement public
d'aménagement paris saclay vous donne
rendez vous le samedi 14 décembre à
partir de 12 heures sur le quartier de
moulon l'objectif est de vous donner
toutes les informations sur le
développement du campus urbain
voilà c'est la fin de cette émission
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi pour plus
d'informations le site eps.fr sinon
regardez tv 78 il dit à très bientôt
[Musique]